i'd like to take the academy and now the
participants present here
it's with great honor that i would like
to introduce and represent the
participation of south america in this
event
uh
my name is lucas i'm an undergraduate
student in statistics at the federal
university of ireland the march
and i'm a moderator at find the attack
and i will start by talking about the
plans and the perspectives for the
contribution of comics large program in
brazil as well as the current scenario
of bioinformatics and why to encourage
the teaching of this area in brazil
so we have about two programs only for
the academic degrees of hd and dac
according to the international society
of computational biology and about just
six universities that offer postgraduate
courses focused on the area of
bioinformatics
with master and doctorate academic
degrees
so in addition to these programs there
are graduate programs in computational
biology that are offered by the theoplus
institute in the national laboratory for
scientific computing
[Music]
it's not stable that bioinformatics is
still a new science in development in
brazil but also in the rest of the world
so
some brazilian states especially in the
northeast
they lack this kind of knowledge and
there is an uneven distribution in the
implementation of bioinformatics
teaching among the brazilian regions
so the use of tools and information
obtained from the development of
bioinformatics can bring significant
advances to the field of education in
brazilian science
in that case a bioinformatics software
is well said that as an educational tool
in different educational institutions in
brazil
because it allows students to associate
the theoretical knowledge of biology and
computing
with the reality through the perhaps in
a virtual environment
so with that in mind
uh omixologic training has been the
focus of my work with buying biotech to
reach the faculty and disseminate this
kind of knowledge in threats among the
students and with that
to encourage these people in the citizen
science of south america to participate
in this community to contribute with the
advancement of this area in the country
so
i will start i will
talking about the precision medicine
before the dr lewis
but
let me briefly highlight a few important
points about the topics of comics data
and bioinformatics in south america
in 2017 the brazilian association of
personalized and precision mixing was
created
there are small technology-based
companies a white field are now able to
identify new markers and develop new
tests that utilize genomics for medicine
in brazil this area is still
underdeveloped
in reality compared to
other countries like the us
but there is a trend to expand and grow
so with that in mind
uh training for new students it's
critical to for the success of this
domain once large training and its
programs are designed to introduce
anyone from a life science background to
the concepts and logic behind omnis data
bioinformatics and their applications
and today i'm excited to share that we
are translating the materials into
portuguese and spanish and we'll be
making them available for free over the
next few months
i'm excited about the potential for
precision medicine
and that we have so much data available
to guide clinicians to adapt this
approach to the needs of patients across
brazil and south america